Hotel Artemis is directed by Drew Pearce
the man who helmed the Marvel one-shot
all hail the king and this has an
amazing cast Jodie Foster Dave Bautista
Stirling Kate Brown sofia boutella Jeff
Goldblum just to name a few and this is
set in a near-future Los Angeles where
there are riots across the entire city
and there's one place called the hotel
Artemus which is run by a nurse played
by Jodie Foster and it's basically a
Members Only emergency room for
criminals you can go there it's a safe
haven you can get fixed up with all this
futuristic medicine and technology and
hopefully stay safe while you might be
on the run from cops and so I was
actually really interested in this film
just based on his concept alone so I was
curious to see what this film could be
and it is a very ambitious movie but I
would say that those ambitions sometimes
outweigh what we actually get it's a
film that really is trying to be a lot
but it takes a long time for the stakes
to be established for the first entire
act I was wondering what the movie was
actually about is it just sort of like
this dry comedy with a little bit of
action where we have like this
futuristic Los Angeles and all these
criminals in one place is it a spy movie
a straight action film or a drama or is
it a movie about regret or a 1970s
grindhouse film Hotel Artemus is trying
to be all of these things and I admire
it for that but it just takes so long to
get going and once it finally does get
going
it doesn't really run at full steam if
you know what I mean like it's a film
that has a lot of tension in regards to
things that are set up potential tension
I should say there is a lot that you
could do with the plot points they
decide to use especially when it comes
to Jodie Foster's character and Dave
Batista's character a nurse and her
extremely powerful orderly who likes to
reference that he's a healthcare
professional quite often which is
definitely one of the better parts of
the film Batista is great he is just
knocking it out of the park with film
roles in regards to understanding his
tendencies and what he can really give
to a movie and Foster is also really
good here too although sometimes I
couldn't quite understand what she was
saying she does a lot of fast talking
and she has an interesting accent that
doesn't always honor percent come across
clear but it was
like I didn't think it was a bad
character choice I thought she was
really good in the film and one of the
more interesting backstories for sure
but when you have a movie where just
about every character is a criminal or
someone who is caring for criminals
you have to really set up why we should
care or why we should feel like we're on
their side and there's a lot of choices
in the screenplay particularly with
sterling K Browns character and his
brother where you understand why they're
in the screenplay there's a relationship
there you're supposed to feel bad for
him you're supposed to care you're
supposed to feel like anything could
happen to his brother and so you're on
edge but I really wasn't it felt like
they were choices that you would expect
to see in a screenplay that need to be
there to have characters with
backstories and relevant personal
problems and commentary about today's
struggles but then they just don't
really pay off in the film because it's
trying to be so many different things
and since it really is just a hotel
filled with people who maybe want to
kill each other but they can't because
there's rules it's going to be compared
to the Continental and the John wick
franchise and it should be because
there's some similarities there where
you have this one place where criminals
have a safe haven they're all murderers
and killers or bank robbers or whatever
but there's rules and so it's original
in the sense that the film feels like
it's something we haven't really seen in
a while but it's really kind of similar
to something else we've gotten recently
that has done it a lot better and so
while this film is very ambitious in
what it tries to do in combining so many
different genres and characters and
feelings it just doesn't pay off in the
end with a story that was compelling
there are scenes with such great
potential when it comes to suspense or
action and it doesn't really feel like
it's utilized there's an amazing
sequence towards the end where Batista
he grabs like this pickaxe or something
I've only seen it once so I think it was
a pickaxe and he's about to stare down
these guys and you're waiting for this
amazing thing and it just it just kind
of fizzles out nothing really happens
you know there's moments like that in
the movie Zachary Quintos in the film
and at one point he just appears like he
teleports someplace and you're wondering
how he arrived there so not only is it a
film that doesn't quite meet its
ambitions it sometimes takes its
characters and
just puts them places they need to be
without really explaining how they
arrived there there are aspects of this
movie that I really appreciated namely
the performances some of the way it
looked the production designs awesome
the hotel itself is really incredible
but you never really feel like what's
happening outside all these riots they
continuously reference on the news it
doesn't seem like it's really much of a
problem because they're in this
incredibly well protected facility and
it's just sort of like this background
thing for the futuristic setting that
doesn't really add that much to the film
in regards to the supporting cast sofia
boutella is great she has one of the
most memorable scenes in the film boo
teesta and foster as I said sterling K
Brown really good stuff Jeff Goldblum
has maybe my favorite line in the movie
there's stuff in the film that you can
appreciate and I feel like some people
will will like this movie and and be
entertained by it or at least like the
concept but I need a little more than
that I need to I need more than just
admiration for what they tried to do
because it doesn't quite work for me in
the end for the entire film from the
beginning to the end I just kept
thinking that was almost a really good
scene that was almost a really good
moment but they just never push it to
that next level that we're starting to
see other films like the John wick films
understand to get to that next level you
just have to really push it's either
gonna be hyper violent or really
well-written or just very stylized and
this film doesn't really have any of
those things it's just kind of it's fine
it's it's an enjoyable movie that looks
good that doesn't quite meet its
ambitions I'm gonna give Hotel Artemis a
C+ guys thank you so much as always for
watching let me know if you saw Hotel
Artemis and what you think of it as
always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck man eyes
[Music]
you